happy Holidays happy holidays neighbor I
know neighbor you've been here for so
long so many years so like what's the
favorite Christmas moment I love it here
at Christmas time do you enjoy it
because this is the busiest time of the
I don't mind it I love it I'm used to it
as well I mean I've been here for like
probably 25 years cuz I've been doing
sir live it looks so good and thank you
I haven't
left traffic is terrible you can't leave
it's better to just stay here for 25
years and just planing your moments that
is insane that's a lot of your life s
live yeah I mean everything it's most of
my life has been here so I mean with the
the tree uh lighting and by the way
great job hosting the tree lighting I
love that perfect perfectly done but the
the ice rink is fun I like to even just
go down and just watch people fall it's
just fun you don't have to you don't
have to ice G if you don't want to but I
mean that FAO is here now oh it's Toy
Story it's just everyone's in a good
mood it's really beautiful down there
and great so I I I I love this time of
year I mean it starts kind of with the
parade too yeah kind of kind for us
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade and The
Roots and I have been doing it for 10
years wow and uh wild it's so funny how
some Christmases since I've done the
Thanksgiving per before like as a singer
for different ones yeah so funny because
sometimes it is fine the weather and
sometimes you are like ice what oh it's
freezing yeah well I think what's fun is
before the parade starts it's like
probably 6:00 in the morning you have to
get all get on a tour bus and wait to
get on the float so that they all go in
the right time so you're on this bus
with a bunch of different people that
are on floats and sometimes you have
different people coming on the bus I
remember one year I was on the bus with
Ronald McDonald I was on that same bus
were you on that bus we were on the same
bus together I tell everyone that story
you do I say I was with Ronald
McDonald's yeah and he talks just like a
do you yell at them he's trying to have
a conversation he's trying to have a
conversation and he's Ronald McDonald's
he's Ronald McDonald he's drinking a
coffee he's like oh man traffic is
terrible I go yeah didn't talk to you
bud you're Ronald McDonald the magic R
don't can't just go and you just be you
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home